those of you in my course on war peace
and strategy will unfortunately hear a
lot of familiar points today but you
probably still shouldn't doze off since
I'll sneak a few new ones into realism
as a messy theory if you take the whole
tradition spanning millennia thinking
about international relations as whether
the major compelling ideas like
Christianity or Marxism original
precepts spawn a lot of sects which
develop in various directions that share
some basic principles but they differ a
lot on many related issues real is
disagree with each other frequently
there are classical realists and
structural or neorealists offensive
realists and defensive realists on
variations of other kinds some realists
are Democrats some Republicans some
Marxists some libertarians so realism
does definitely not provide a formula
for policy in any detail and this will
lead some practical people to be
impatient with the notion that grappling
with the theories necessary or worth the
time my bias is eclectic I've been
accused in print by a realist of being a
non realist and by an unrealistic being
a realist
I do believe realism is inadequate in
many respects but I view it as Winston
Churchill viewed democracy I think
realism is the worst theory of
international relations except for all
the others now remember these paradigms
we deal with and we insist inflicting on
you at Columbia or general
predispositions a few people's views fit
very snugly in any of the paradigms
except for a few fanatics I know th
Carr's reflections and the limitations
of realism which includes in a book
which is otherwise a consummate
statement of realest thought now some
people believe realism is a scientific
theory and others that it's really just
an attitude toward the human condition i
incline more toward the latter view in
any case realism is a general theory
about how the world
usually works but it's not a formula for
predicting how things will work in
specific cases where particular
circumstances idiosyncrasies of
political leaders or other sources of
chance may produce decisions by
governments that don't accord with the
tenants of realist theory classical
realism we usually think of in terms of
the tradition of Thucydides Machiavelli
Hobbes and in more recent times Hans
Morgenthau and EH Carr Reinhold Niebuhr
it emphasizes flaws in human nature the
natural prevalence of conflicts of
interests power seeking motives the
dominance of material interests over
legal or moral norms in determining the
actions of political units mainly
nation-states but within fractured
policies they're undergoing civil war
contending groups that want to create or
replace regimes and build new states
Robert Gilpin notes three assumptions of
realism first the essentially
conflictual nature of international
affairs second that the essence of
social reality is the group not the
individuals of liberal thought or the
classes of Marxism Homo sapiens is a
tribal species he says and third the
primacy in all political life of power
and security and human motivation this
is not to say that power and security
are the sole or even the most important
objectives
Gilpin writes he says we prize beauty
truth and goodness what the realist
seeks distress is that all these more
noble goals will be lost unless one
makes provision for one security in the
power struggle among social groups but
more recently structural near realism or
neo realism associated with Kenneth
waltz and John Mearsheimer try to
present a more rigorously scientific
formulation of the realist tradition on
the emphasize even more the causal
effect of international anarchy in
another book that you're not assigned
for this course at least waltzes men the
state and war he talks about the
difference between permissive and
efficient causes
the permissive cause is what makes
something possible though not inevitable
and the efficient cause is what makes it
happen in a particular instance the
permissive cause is the international
system defined in terms of anarchy
there's just no sovereign above the
level of States or as he quotes Rousseau
wars occur because there is nothing to
prevent them now note and this anarchy
does not mean chaos or constant violence
it means simply the lack of a sovereign
the lack of enforcement authority above
the level of the state without world
government anarchy makes States or
groups within countries without coherent
or effective functioning States makes
them the ultimate judges and enforces of
their own rights and interests Mahler
material rights and interests as they
see them when states are groups and
civil conflict disagree about whose
claims are legitimate power determines
which of the claims will prevail noting
the counter power can prevent the use of
force by a state or group that considers
the status quo unacceptable for the
efficient cause Walt says look to the
levels of analysis below the
international system domestic politics
particularly ders in ideologies there's
a prevalent misconception that Walt's
believes that domestic factors don't
matter he thinks they matter a great
deal if you're trying to explain why
something happens at a particular time
and he makes an important distinction
which is lost on many people between a
theory of international politics and a
theory of foreign policy theory of
international politics is about average
outcomes over time
why wars recur a theory or foreign
policy is one that explains why a
government makes a decision for or
against war in particular circumstances
for particular reasons Walt says a man's
state in war war may result because
state a has something that state B wants
the efficient cause of the war
as the desire of state B the permissive
cause is the fact there's nothing to
prevent state B from undertaking the
risks of war he goes on if an effect is
produced by two or more causes the
effect is not permanently eliminated by
removing one of them and endeavour
launched against one cause to the
neglect of others may make the situation
worse instead of better thus as the
Western democracies became more inclined
to peace Hitler became more belligerent
the increased propensity to peace of
some participants international politics
may increase rather than decrease the
likelihood of war anarchy defines
political order in the international
sphere because there's no world
government no legislature court or
executive complete with police force to
arrest those who violate the law and
threaten public order
that's why waltz calls the international
system a self-help system or as John
Mearsheimer says what happens when a
country calls 9 1 1 11 there's no one on
the other end of the line there is no
911 'it's a is the United Nations 9 1 1
or NATO or Uncle Sam no it's not the
same those organs are like a friendly
neighbor you can call on to ask for help
if you're getting burglarized there are
only organizations with member countries
who may or may not come to your aid if
it suits them bonkie moon has no troops
of his own and never will have at least
until the United Nations becomes some
form of world government you can try
calling a friendly neighbor another
country you want to ally with and
support you but whether that neighbor
comes to your aid is up to her when
Kuwait called in 1990 we answered and
came when Darth were called last year
this year we said sorry can't make it
this time there's no organized
institutionalized enforcement authority
always standing by in the international
system that you can count on to make
governments or groups do the right thing
as we've seen the united nations in the
world court in the hague don't fill the
bill when the World Court gave a verdict
against the United States on the mining
of Nicaraguan harbors in the 1980's the
Reagan administration said get lost and
nothing happened to the United States
nobody arrested the United States and
sent it to prison maybe somebody should
have but no one no international
institution no other government could so
no one did in the international system
you're on your own you and your friends
have to act as your own court and your
own police or else submit to whoever
else is willing to do so multilateral
enforcement for example NATO's action
against Serbia in 1999 the war over
Kosovo is not analogous to domestic law
enforcement by courts or legal
authorities rather it's more analogous
to vigilantes organizing a posse same
logic can apply to conflicts within
States the civil wars or revolutions
when central government institutions
collapse or when large segments of
populations no longer consider them
legitimate and seek to overthrow them or
cc'd from them at that point you can say
there's Anarchy within the state until
orders re-established by a new regime or
partition that comes out of the Civil
War
just like anarchy that's the permanent
condition in the international system a
realists are most focused on the problem
of war and peace unlike liberals or
constructivists who are at least as
interested in probably more so in some
other issues such as economic
development and trade ideology character
domestic regimes and other big issues
that affect human welfare how do they as
opposed to other schools of thought see
the problem of war
well one difference I think that defines
the instincts a lot of people bring to
this question is the difference between
seeing the cause of war and evil or in
tragedy to oversimplify very roughly
liberals tend to assume the problem of
war comes from evil and realist tend to
a
assume that it comes from tragedy evil
in the sense of aggression aggression
comes from human nature and sin bad
people commit aggression aggression is a
crime or aggression comes from bad
states bad regimes while good states
only defend themselves autocracies make
war democracies make peace and so on the
view that emphasizes tragedy tends to
believe that war comes from genuine
conflicts of interests sometimes in
which both sides have reasonable claims
or certainly claims that they themselves
see as reasonable or it can come from
misunderstanding misperception
miscalculation the problem of the
security dilemma the security dilemma
image means that you have two states
neither of whom want war with each other
but who are suspicious of each other's
intentions so state a in order to guard
against the worst possibilities starts
arming itself so that state B can't take
advantage of it state B sees state
arming and says uh-oh
we'd better tool up to and starts
increasing its armaments state a then
sees then says AHA we knew it they're
out to get us and you get this
figurative cycle or escalation of action
and reaction competition that increases
suspicion and tension causes arms races
may make crises more likely and at worst
potentially inadvertent war well which
is the main danger the security dilemma
or aggression and a way these notions
are capsulized and the prevalent images
people have of the origins of World War
1 in World War 2 in 1914 the image many
have is that a cycle of action and
reaction got out of control and the
states of Europe were unable to escape
the escalation that led to war
even though none of them really
I wanted what followed whereas in 1938
at Munich people seeking to avoid
exactly that problem of escalating
tension solve the problem they thought
in a different way by reassuring Germany
but turned out to be wrong about Germans
the Germans ambitions and the limits of
those ambitions and ended up allowing
aggression to succeed but how do you
know which situation you're in that is
often what the most intense national
security debates are about there are
risks of misperception in either
direction you can try to deter a state
you're worried about but then risk
provoking it if you assume aggression is
the danger while the reality is the
security dilemma as in the popular image
in 1914 or you can reassure that state
and be victimized if it's real intent is
aggressive as with Germany at the end of
the 1930s I also find it useful to sort
of clarify some images to make analogies
to domestic law and adjudication those
who focus on the problem of evil or
unprovoked aggression and to see war as
a matter figuratively of criminal law
one transgressor is at fault like a
murderer a thief who threatens domestic
peace and that transgressor has to be
stopped
and taken out of action instead of
Charles Manson or Ted Bundy and domestic
arenas
it's an Adolphe hitler or a saddam
hussein those who focus on tragedy or
misunderstanding tend to see war is a
problem more akin to civil law where
disputes over contracts or divorce or
similar matters have two sides where
right and wrong are not always clearly
divided where both sides believe
themselves to be in the right whichever
the case may be
why do political disputes produce war
rather than
litigation because litigation only
resolves problems when either both
parties to the case accept the
legitimacy and finality the court's
decision even if it goes against them or
if either the parties does not accept it
the court can enforce its decision it
does that by dispatching police to
arrest offending parties and put them in
jail or by garnishing a salary to pay a
judgment or by seizing property and
transferring it to the party who won the
suit litigation would have worked in
regard to the mining of Nicaraguan
harbors if the world court in the hague
could have punished the United States
the point is within a state a court can
make its writ stick because there's an
executive authority to enforce it there
is no comparable structure of excepted
legitimate Authority or an enforcement
power in the international system to
repeat myself or within failed States or
ones written by rebellion and this is
above all what realism emphasizes about
the meaning of anarchy in fact war is
the real analog to litigation in the
international system peaceful
settlements are analogous to settling
out of court in domestic legal disputes
in the domestic legal system if you're
getting a divorce or challenging the
interpretation of the question of will
or suing a contractor for fraud it's in
everyone's interest normally to reach a
settlement out of court because
litigation is expensive and it could
leave both parties to the dispute worse
off than if they can agree on a
resolution of the dispute don't have to
pay all that money for lawyers for years
on end but sometimes it proves
impossible to settle out of court and
litigation and sooths same in
international disputes usually the
parties to international disputes
settled peacefully because they know
what would be awful might leave them
both worse off but sometimes they can't
agree and the equivalent litigation
violent contest and so
a some that sometimes have hoped that
the United Nations would be that
supranational Authority that could
enforce international law that so-called
global governance would supersede
self-help in the international system
and rein in the resort to war but
exactly what is the difference between
global governance and world government I
know their political scientists will
make very clear what the difference is
but in my obtuse way I just went to the
dictionary and looked and the dictionary
doesn't distinguish the two very clearly
in any case the United Nations is not a
world government
so should warriors now proclaim that the
United Nations is in crisis because the
United States ignores it when deciding
to wage war no or at least not the
current crisis is newer or deeper and in
the past I'd say the United Nations
recently has just reverted to what it
has been for most of its history that is
during the Cold War and the real
unmasking of the United Nations
overreaching the post Cold War era came
long before the United States ignored it
in attacking Iraq and this I think
illustrates some of the criticisms that
realists level at idealists who don't
pay attention to power and that is I'd
say the real unmasking of the limits of
the United Nations came in 1995 at
Schreber and Nitze when the United
Nations boldly proclaimed a safe area
for Bosnian Muslims to be protected from
attack by Bosnian Serbs problem was the
UN had no means to enforce it if I
recall correctly as one puny dutch
battalion which when faced with the Serb
army just melted away as a result of
that approximately 7,000 Bosnian Muslims
by most prominent estimates were rounded
up and murdered I think it's a shameful
but classic example of what realism sees
as folly
the reliance on law or rhetoric to
protect people without backing by
military power realisms argument is if
you make demands or assurances that you
can't back up with power you're foolish
at best and at worst horribly
destructive it's been a lot of rhetoric
about the rule of international law but
a realist would say the only law that
rules is the interpretation of
international law by the most powerful
states in the system when they disagree
about what international law really says
as prosecution and defense attorneys
disagree in domestic courtrooms the law
has no effect independent of power
claims of universal jurisdiction which
would become more popular in recent
times a really statements of aspiration
or wishful ninh thus view when a great
power refuses to sign a treaty it's not
bound by the tree despite what some
observers now assert as when they claim
that treaties like the NPT the
non-proliferation treaty become binding
once they've passed a certain threshold
and the number of ratifications even
binding on those who don't adhere to
them but the United States is not going
to be bound by the International
Criminal Court whether it should be or
not and in fact the United States is
using its power to induce other
countries to back off from their
adherents the international court by
exempting Americans in those countries
from the jurisdiction of the ICC power
Trump's law in other ways in
international life that differ
profoundly from the role of law inside
stable societies realists would argue
for example Belgium was compelled to
scale back its own war crimes law in
order to appease the United States after
the US government threatened to move
NATO headquarters out of Belgium what
about realism and morality is a
prevalent image of realism as a moral in
one sense this is true but not really
instead I think it has to be understood
in terms of utilitarian or Contin
Quen chillest versions of morality where
ethics are shaped by the imperatives of
survival and see the Holzmann and leave
an article on that that your sign I
apologized I recommended Eliot Cohen's
and my little article be assigned before
I had read the leavin one which you can
probably get away with substituting for
that if you haven't read them all yet
Hans Morgenthau would emphasize that you
should focus on the difference between
what is and what ought to be between the
desirable and the possible if what's
desirable is not possible trying to do
what's desirable may be at best futile
at worst counterproductive and
destructive realists worry about paving
the road to hell with good intentions
this rubber needs a yesterday Darfur
tomorrow eh car argues that idealist
wishing dominate thinking and that
realists make thinking dominate wishing
Robert Gilpin writes moral commitment
lies at the heart of realism
what Morgenthau and many other realists
have in common is a belief that ethical
and political behavior will fail unless
it takes into account the actual
practice of states and the teaching of
sound theory Machiavelli argues in
various ways that sometimes the prince
has to do evil in order to do good thus
in the liberal tradition of the West
Machiavellian has a pejorative
connotation and it is often said the
ends do not justify the means well of
course the ends don't always justify the
means but they must sometime if you ever
believe in waging war for any purpose
because a decision to wage war including
in self-defense
simply resisting an attack means a
decision to get a lot of people killed
who might otherwise live a decision that
that is the lesser evil a decision that
defending some value whether it's a
humanitarian relief for benign
or your own political integrity or
anything else is the lesser evil
compared to war at that point if you
believe the end never justifies the
means then it seems to me you can never
believe in any war however noble or just
the asserted purpose might be no war
against Hitler to prevent National
Socialism for ruling all of Europe no
war against the Confederacy in the
United States in the 1860s to free the
slaves no war for anything but if you
believe that some things are worth
killing for some values are so important
self-defense or other values then you're
on that slippery slope of deciding
exactly when and how much certain ends
may justify certain means Morgenthau
emphasizes that realists aim for the
lesser evil and they subordinate
abstract principle to material interest
essentially a pragmatic argument and
since also the difference between what
Max Weber calls the ethic of absolute
ends and the ethic of responsibility in
other words a realist would say no
principle should be honored to the
absolute if it has awful consequences so
in a way one thing that illustrates this
argument starkly and in a way that may
be surprising to modern sensibilities is
the the lining of the controversy over
the lying Baptists and I don't remember
the details but essentially if I recall
somewhat correctly there's a controversy
in the 19th century between different
sects of Baptists over this hypothetical
situation if a family on the frontier is
attacked by Indians
or Native Americans and the parents tell
the kids to go out and hide in a culvert
behind the barn and the Indians take the
parents prisoners and ask if there's
anyone else there should parents tell
the truth and say the children are out
behind the barn or should they lie and
say no
one else is here and the argument was
for some the absolute principle that you
must not lie had to be honored because
you couldn't compromise the principle
the pragmatic counter-argument is that's
ridiculous because then that gets your
children killed well that may seem the
simplistic form of the argument but in
more complex ways that is part of the
realist critique of taking principles
too far or the example Morgenthau gave
about the Soviet invasion of Finland in
1939 2:40 after the outbreak of war over
Poland British wanted to aid the Finns
against the Soviets and were prevented
because Sweden wouldn't allow troops to
transit their country and Morgenthau his
argument was how insane it was for the
British to think about going to war with
the Soviet Union at that point to defend
Finland just over the principle of
aggression when they're already as it
were fighting for their lives against
Germany this would have been cutting
their own throats would it have been
moral to invite defeat in war at the
price of letting the Nazis ruled Europe
just uphold Finland's legal rights in a
certain way one might argue and I may be
reveal my biases you see something of
that with neoconservative arguments
about Iran today there are some arguing
that the United States should attack
Iran despite the fact that we happen to
be bogged down in a catastrophic war in
Iraq already realists would criticize
that as unwise at best
realisms view on the use of force as an
instrument of policy is sometimes
misconstrued there's a prevalent notion
that realists are Hawks
I'd like to use force no at least not
all the time they're Hawks about
preparing capabilities for war but much
less so about fighting wars when they
can be avoided there's no simple
correlation between ideological values
or international relations theories an
opinion on the use of force during the
Cold War both realists and liberals were
split on the matter of the Vietnam War
you had realists like George Kennan
opposing the war and a realist like
Henry Kissinger supporting it
similarly you had liberal senators like
scoop Jackson and George McGovern on
opposite ends of that issue some people
forget that Jackson's ad a rating was
higher than George McGovern's Jackson
was a big supporter of the war well
unbalanced
the question is what's the standard for
going to war realist would tend to say
that it's when important national
interests in a material sense or the
maintenance of the balance of power is
at stake whereas liberals would tend to
say that it should be when political
values or moral principles are at stake
plenty of exceptions to this simplistic
formulation but I think that's the sort
of crayon version of the difference and
the post Cold War era who was most often
calling for the use of force by the
United States for intervention with
military means I think it was more often
liberal Hawks you didn't find many
people identified as realists clamoring
to go to war in the Balkans or Iraq and
then you have the phenomenon of the
present president the United States who
started out as some rough already cents
more or less cautious realist saying the
United States shouldn't be involved in
nation building or
interventions here and there but then
was converted overnight by the events of
September 11th into a liberal Crusader
why do reals is so much on military
power war is never a first choice
instrument policy but it's always an
available instrument it's preferred when
other instruments fail and the
alternative of peace poses unacceptable
losses force is the ultimate ratio regum
that is the final arbiter of disputes
when all else all peaceful means and the
negotiation and bargaining failed to
resolve it most disputes are settled
without violence because no one wants to
spend blood and treasure if it can be
avoided but occasionally conflict of
interest proves intractable compromise
proves infeasible and neither side would
rather concede than fight then force of
the threat of force determines who rules
on the matter countries need military
power not because war is likely but just
because it's possible they need to keep
military forces at the ready in
peacetime because they never know when
things may go bad when an adversary may
change his intentions and intentions can
change quickly overnight in an election
or coup d'etat or a cabinet shuffle but
modern military capabilities cannot
change overnight it takes many years to
feel the modern Army Navy and Air Force
it takes time to convert resources into
mobilized force structures to recruit
organize equip train and deploy them in
forms capable of combat so if you want
the option to fight next year you need
to have begun preparing many years ago
now here I'm talking about modern
warfare not primitive low-tech warfare
that has characterized much of recent
conflict the international system in the
Balkans and Africa in the 1990s or
insurgencies in Iraq and Afghanistan
today
one statement compatible with realism
was used graphically by someone who has
generally identified as a critical
realism that's Joseph Nye who was a
Harvard professor and served in the
Carter State Department and in the
course of the rebirth of the Cold War in
the 1970s began adjusting some of the
ideas he had become famous for in
academia declaring the declining eighth
ility of force and the obsolescence of
realism and he later served as assistant
secretary of defense in the clinton
administration but nice said security is
like oxygen you never worry about it
until you don't have it and then it's
all you worry about so military power in
a sense is the emergency oxygen tank for
the rare occasions when an adversary may
suck security away realists believe that
war is natural natural meaning what
occurs in nature not meaning good just
natural as States are also subject to
natural selection now it's true in
recent years not many states have gone
out of business completely although
historically a number did but a lot of
them suffer a great deal Germany lost a
third of its territory in the 20th
century as a result of trying to enlarge
itself in the last century Mexico lost
almost half its territory to guess who
and there are other examples so states
need military power to prevent war if
possible and if they can't prevent it to
win it
military power may also hopefully
prevent war via deterrence that is by
making clear to an adversary that if she
attacks either your successful defense
or your devastating retaliation will
make her wish she had answered that the
costs exceed the games and therefore
prevent the resort to
work in this sense military power need
not be used to be useful that the most
successful use of military power is when
it remains in the background and never
has to actually be employed in combat
it's always in the background of
diplomacy on significant international
political disputes even when the option
to use force doesn't appear to be on the
table now this is not true of all
negotiations of course not
that trade negotiations or disputes on
many matters but regarding any dispute
over who will make the final political
decision on a matter of vital political
interest closet's said the combat is
like cash payment and commerce there are
a lot of interactions and deals that
occur without any money actually
changing hands
but always in the background of all
these deals is what would happen at the
end of the day when money does change
hands similarly many deals are made many
coercive actions undertaken in
international affairs that are shaped by
the estimates of what would happen if it
were to come to blows military power may
keep some grievances from being pursued
since it's clear that the weaker party
can't do anything to force a
rectification of injustice why is Mexico
stopped complaining about all the
territory the United States grabbed from
it in the 1840s well I suspect one
reason as I know it can't do anything
about it
realism focuses on military power
because it determines whose claims
prevail when disagreements can't be
resolved by negotiation so war is about
who rules who controls the disposition
of whatever states are in dispute who
calls the tune in peacetime after the
shooting stops for realists this usually
means which countries will are more
importantly will not control
internationally the international system
or which groups will control the
government within a country in a civil
war
for liberals usually this means which
type of regime will rule within
countries thus realists generally prefer
not to intervene in civil wars unless
the result is likely to affect the
balance of power among states while
liberals believe ultimate stability of
the international system depends on the
quality of governments within it and
thus are more interested in promoting
democratization and improvements of
governments sometimes by force consider
Bosnia why did some oppose Western
intervention and others support it
liberals tended to see the Serbs as
culprits guilty of aggression or war
crimes realists tend to see the moral
claims as less clear or more mixed and
so the issue as being in a gray area
rather than one a black avoir or black
or white liberals in the West in the
early 1990s wanted to intervene to stop
bloodshed and rollback serb conquests
but few wanted to pay very significant
costs for doing so
liberals want enforcement but often back
away if the price is much bloodshed
finally in 1995 NATO did some serious
bombing which in combination with the
unilateral Croatian offensive in on the
ground in Creina put the Serbs on the
defensive we got the Dayton agreements
which appeared to settle the war
peacefully but how by incorporating
mutually contradictory provisions that
aimed in principle to reestablish
and integrate a unitary Bosnian state
but also recognized de facto the
partition of the country among the three
contending ethnic groups the settlement
thus did not settle the political
question the question of who rules and
rested on the continuing presence and
policing by outside occupiers so I can
only wonder how Iraq and we will avoid
that fate in the United States really
shape and control some rocky transition
toward democracy in a way that doesn't
leave the Shiites attempting to impose
tyranny of the majority or leaving the
Kurds determined to exclude the rid of
Baghdad's Authority leaving the Sunnis
desperate to prevent
marginalization in such a situation be
brought about without going from current
low grade Civil War to all-out civil war
realists would be skeptical that it's
going to be possible to do that without
a much larger war liberals would be more
hopeful that the process of government
developments and reconciliation may
avoid that and all this also indicates
that war is usually about States the
relations between them in the
international sphere or regarding civil
wars or revolutions or Wars of
Independence about how States will be
formed and organized and controlled
whose state it will be under what
conditions its realisms emphasis on
States pass a there's a lot more
sentiment in that direction perhaps
right after the Cold War before a number
of things started going sour again but
also the conflicts of post September
11th world are not so clearly about
States the perpetrators of those attacks
were transnational group concerned
mainly with opposing the effect of
American power and perhaps Western
culture on numerous societies
so this evokes the question of new
cleavages and world politics argued by
Samuel Huntington Anne's book The Clash
of Civilizations in their remaking a
world order which I see is a
constructivist argument about
international conflict and order but
States certainly are critical
ingredients in any political violence
formation of an any terrorist coalition
for example depends on States US
military action against the Taliban and
al-qaeda in the Middle East depends on
relations with governments that supply
bases and cooperate in anti-terror
campaigns
Pakistan is Becca Stan Saudi Arabia and
others it's often said that states have
become much less important in world
politics the globalization reduces the
ability of states to control things does
this mean then that war has become less
important perhaps is even becoming
obsolete
well first there's less to the decline
of the state than meets the eye in some
respects states now have less control
over some important aspects especially
of economics than they once did
yet states remain alive and kicking and
it's interesting how many people in so
many places around the world since the
end of the Cold War had been fighting
like hell to get and shape their own
states and some who see globalization is
an unprecedented wave of the future
perhaps exaggerate how much control
states had traditionally and indeed
states loom larger in the lives of their
citizens than they did in earlier times
Kenneth waltz likes to point out that
Western states now dispose of far larger
proportions of gross economic product of
their societies than ever before and for
some reason there have been more people
organized and organized groups in the
world in the past few years as I said
fighting fiercely to establish their own
states or take control of them than ever
before in the past century whether it's
Bosnia Tajikistan Cambodia Afghanistan
Armenia Azerbaijan Rwanda Kosovo Sudan
East Timor Chechnya and the list goes on
some contemporary Wars take place in
weak failed or non-existent States for
example Somalia or Congo but they're
about States attempts to create States
to take control of them and reshape them
or develop them into functioning
authorities or at least if not in the
sense of some elaborate articulated
modern nation-state at least a political
unit that at least provides
opportunities for kleptocracy well as
realism a guide for policy said it's not
a formula for policy and has also always
been an argument about whether realism
is an empirical theory or a normative
one and I'd say the answer is both
essentially it's an argument that the
odds are over time if states or groups
do not act in a certain way to watch out
for their power
position they're going to be vulnerable
and suffer for it and therefore since
that happens as a matter of reality
states have to act in accord with those
principles to survive and therefore they
should do it that's a somewhat circular
and confusing argument but I think
that's essentially most real estate
they're charged with making an argument
that it's both the way the world works
and criticizing governments for not
acting in the way that we like and
dictates sometimes realists and liberals
are constructivists agree on what policy
choices should be made but for different
reasons and sometimes realists disagree
among themselves about what should be
done in the specific case as much as
they do with other schools of thought
the main point that differentiates
realists is their focus on how policy
options depend on and will affect the
balance of power in the international
system as opposed to what the legal or
moral principles in dispute are which
are the priorities to idealist some
examples of situations where realism and
idealism diverge I mentioned the Winter
War in Finland in 1939 240 or Nixon and
the rat Prussia Mall with China in 1972
Nixon was a conservative and China was
at that time in the midst of the
Cultural Revolution
now ISM was the ultimate anti liberal
ideology viewed at that time is every
bit as wild and crazy as North Korea or
Iran or Saddam Hussein's Iraq have been
viewed in your lifetimes but the realist
argument that Nixon Kissinger had was
essentially in order to counterbalance a
rising Soviet Union yes at that time so
Union was seen as rising that the
ideological differences the difference
in values that was so profound between
the United States and China had to be
disregarded in order to form a tacit
reliance against the Soviet Union Iraq
in 1991 after the first Persian Gulf War
you had the realist view that was
dominant in daddy Bush's administration
people like Brent Scowcroft or the old
Dick Cheney
before his hard operations making the
prudent argument that it was not a good
idea to try to overthrow Saddam Hussein
because would threatened to break up
Iraq make it ran more powerful the
opposition may be most articulately
voiced by Paul Wolfowitz saying that we
had encouraged the Iraqis to revolt we
put them out on a limb especially what
happened with the Shiites in the South
after the end of the war and the Kurds
in the north and that we were morally
bound to support them and to do
everything we could to overthrow Saddam
Hussein because his regime was so awful
I also mentioned threat Burnitz in 1995
un legalism without backing by military
power and a massacre what about in the
future what would realism
liberalism suggest about how to handle
us-chinese relations if China continues
to rise economically should the United
States want China to develop
economically to become rich and
prosperous as it had been doing for the
past 25 years
well liberals who generally say sure
economic interdependence Foster's peace
now this is opposed to the argument in
waltzes book the interdependence causes
conflict but in liberal ideology trading
system based on comparative advantage
and peaceful competition makes both the
United States and China richer and
better off so rich China will be a
bigger market for American products more
Chinese military power won't matter
because mutual interests in cooperation
for economic purposes to profit through
peaceful exchange rather than
destructive conflict will prevent
military conflict which would only seem
irrational realists though would be
probably more inclined to say probably
not the United States should not be
happy about an economically developing
China the argument being that a rich
China will be powerful and more able to
throw its weight around
and threaten the interests of the United
States and its allies in the region that
growing power creates growing ambitions
and if there's nothing bad or evil or
wrong about this it's natural
Robert Gilpin's argument that a rising
challenge to a hegemonic power often
produces a war of hegemonic transition
is realism a guide for dealing with the
war on terror well it's not a perfect
framework for understanding radical
Islamist reaction against the West
al-qaeda's militants or other aspects of
the problem al Qaeda is a collection of
transnational non-state actors al Qaeda
and many other terrorist groups are
idealists more than realists conflict
with West is in large part conflict of
ideals
so perhaps constructivism and realism
and some combination might be better
than liberalism for diagnosing the
Islamist terrorist threat liberalism
would tend to emphasize the importance
of spreading Western democracy and
values as a way of getting at the root
causes of terrorism I'm not trying to
tar all liberals with this given the
unpopularity because current president
but I'd say this is in large part the
argument of the bush the youngers
administration after September 11th
their argument that American values are
really universal values and that the
challenge is to do in the evildoers in
order to solve the problem of course the
counter-argument then is that Western
values aren't part what provokes the
problem that energizes the opposition
from radical Islamists what about
constructivism well most of the
constructivists we read in academia tend
at least in the norms they value to be
liberal in some form rather the
huntingtin variant is somewhat different
where Huntington argues in favor of
non-intervention in other
culture areas as necessary to keep the
clash of civilizations which he believes
is real from becoming a war of
civilizations which he wants to avoid
and by the way if like so many people
your view of Huntington's argument is
what appeared in the original article in
foreign affairs 15 years ago bear in
mind that people often infer things from
that that are not what he argues if you
read the whole book especially the last
chapter
sometimes realism and idealism converge
and sometimes realists are split
convergence for example the Titanic
struggles against German fascism and
Japanese militarism in the 1940s and
against Soviet Communism in the Cold War
United realists and liberals because all
of those enemies combined both great
military power and alien ideologies and
values realists were concerned with
might and liberals who are concerned
with right both pointed to a militant
Western policy of war against the axis
and containment against the Soviet Union
this was not true after the Cold War one
of the reasons for the decline of
realism in favor it tends to follow
events in the real world after the Cold
War there was no major military threat
to the West
no globe-spanning ideology to compete
with Western liberalism on the same
scale that Marxism Leninism did the
issue is should powerful states stand
down and remain vigilant but restrained
intervention abroad or should they take
the opportunity to use force to advance
Western values and reshape other
countries in our image realists tend
toward the former non interventionist
view as as I argued though they're not
United than that and liberals tend
toward the latter wilsonian use of force
to reform non liberal regimes or create
a safer liberal international order
there are splits among realists some
interventionist believing that bad
regimes abroad will come to threaten
Western security in the future so for
example in 2003 most realists probably
opposed the American invasion of Iraq
but some who believed Saddam Hussein was
crazy and might you
wmd once he had enough favored war this
was symbolized on the up bed page of the
New York Times on September 22nd 2002
and there was a quarter page anti-war ad
signed by 33 scholars of security
studies mostly identified as realists
next to a huge op-ed essay by Ken
Pollock that disciple of Barry Posen one
of the signers of the ad but
recommending invasion and sometimes anti
interventionist realists misjudged
threats
eh Carr endorsed appeasement indeed that
was one of the principal motives behind
that book and Chamberlain was probably
more realistic Churchill Churchill was
if anything an idealist so where I and
32 others who signed that anti invasion
ad in September 2002 Chamberlain's and
Pollock Churchill don't think so but you
never know for sure until you get the
verdict of history I mean we all think
of Churchill as a savior of Western
civilization now but in June 1940 ah it
didn't look like a very good bet Britain
was alone Germany ruled the continent of
Europe what sense did it make to fight
on when they might have struck a deal
with Germany and there's evidence that
Hitler was willing to let the British
keep their empire as long as it let him
keep the continent but Churchill said no
you know we'll fight on the beaches will
fight in the hedgerows we will never
surrender and there's one famous line of
his that's really grisly says if this
island story of ours must end let it be
when all of us are lying on the ground
choking in our own blood not a realist
rationale that puts material interest
above all know the basic problem was the
eh Carr and Chamberlain and most other
people at the time of the Munich
Agreement in 1938 believed it was a
great triumph because it avoided another
catastrophe like World War one and that
Hitler while is a nasty opportunistic
statement statesman was not crazy and
therefore he could do a deal with them
what they didn't recognize was that he
was not a normal opportunistic
real-estate ceman they didn't realize
that Hitler wasn't I
delist who put his principles about the
German folk and expansion to the east
and other rights of the Germans our
whole society that the only political
debates in the United States are between
contending schools within liberalism so
realism is not an answer the positive
things that you want to accomplish to
make the world a better place but
realism I think helps to suggest what's
necessary to prevent negative
developments that threaten to cripple
your ability to do good well I can
follow up on any of that or any other
things you want to bring up